hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ihr wisst ja alle
selbstverständlich bescheid das ganz
normale Youtube reactions von mir nur
noch auf meinem zweitkanal hochgeladen
werden da bin ich aktuell sehr aktiv
jeden Tag kommen der neue Videos und ihr
wisst das natürlich weil ihr alle schon
selbstverständlich Abonnent seid
wenn nicht
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht Mensch
heute auf so einem gammligen Sonntag
hier in Köln es ist es regnet es schneit
ich habe mir gedacht wir machen heute
endlich mal wieder eine ganz normale
reaction hier auf Luca Kanal und zwar
auf dieses Video hier findet das
richtige Logo was wird welches ist das
korrekte Netflix Logo rechts
100% rechts links sieht total komisch
aus ohne diesen Schatten bei dem
Schrägstrich es ist dieses hier
mit Ansage alles richtig
Profi machen wir es etwas schwieriger
welches ist das richtige PayPal Logo
PayPal oder Paypal also ganz klar links
die fangen mit einer leichten Farbe an
und das Paul ist dann dieses dunklere
blau
vermutlich streamst du tagtäglich Musik
aber weißt du auch wie viele Striche
Spotify hat drei
da steht für die drei Musketiere
genau es sind drei Linien
mit Ansage welches Logo ist hier das
richtige jetzt auch richtig links ich
habe mal mit Cartoon Network
zusammengearbeitet bei einer
anti-mobbing-kampagne deswegen bin ich
mir da ziemlich sicher links ja das ist
es danke
für den Bestätigung ich habe drei Leben
eins ist weg wegen diesem PayPal aber
der Glaube das ist liebst du Kaffee dann
ist das etwas für Dich welches Logo ist
korrekt ich finde es gibt kein
schlimmeres Getränk als Kaffee
so einen kalten mit ganz viel Zucker und
Karamell okay aber hier ist auf jeden
Fall das linke Logo das richtige dieses
natürlich na klar hallo guck mal hier
Qualität und kennst du auch Dominos
Pizza welches ist das richtige Logo
rechts nee es ist links es ist links
weil wenn die das bearbeitet hätten
hätten dieses das ist safe links weil
hier steht Dominos eigentlich es ist
dieses
okay ein Leben nur noch als weit
gereister fernsehprofi kennst du
vielleicht auch das richtige NBC Logo ah
okay also ich glaube es ist 100%ig da
bin ich noch relativ sicher links glaube
ich
das
aber es war ja auch klar gelb orange
blablabla und das hier diese pink pinke
was sind das hier kommt eins für euch
welches ist das richtige
Robins ich würde sagen safe safe rechts
die mehr wenn ich 100% sicher aber ich
habe immer das Gefühl dass dunklere
Farben dieses blau rosa rosa blau ja ich
Farbe eine Mastercard dann musst du ja
auch das Logo kennen das dunklere Farben
er immer immer
Mastercard 100%ig das rechte Logo
100%ig rot gelb immer immer rot gelb so
wie Mario nee ja das ist es rot und gelb
Mario blöd das ist eine teure Marke aber
du hast sie sicher schon oft gesehen
also worauf tippst du bei Monte im
Gesicht habe ich das gesehen
das rechte Logo sieht doch deutlich
schöner aus ist die alle gleich lang
sind ja klar
bist du ein macmensch oder eher ein
Microsoft beides welches Logo ist das
richtige ich nutze Microsoft hier für
Videos aufnehmen etc aber Mac für alles
andere weil das Betriebssystem so viel
besser ist aber das richtige Logo ist
das linke sehe ich tatsächlich hier
unten reingeblendet aber das korrekte
Logo ist dieses wir machen uncut direkt
weiter in Amerika ist Coca-Cola das am
meisten verzehrte Getränk war der zweite
Platz geht an die erdkola aber welches
Logo ist jetzt das richtige warte mal
ganz kurz pausieren also nicht wegen dem
Logo Logo 100% das linke aber
das ist die trinken mehr Cola und auch
mehr Diät Cola als andere Sachen wie
beispielsweise Wasser menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend das war einfach oder
dieses natürlich aber wie krank ist
Amerika und wer belegt den dritten Platz
Pepsi wie sieht denn dieses Logo aus
Pepsi ist definitiv das linke Logo und
wenn man Pepsi mal umdreht steht da ein
oder rückwärts liest oder nee umdreht
einfach also es ist dieses wenn man das
Logo äh diese Bilder genau an und unter
identifiziere das gute alte Disney
Schloss ja Disney Schloss ist rechts
wenn man das Pepsi Logo umdreht einmal
um 180 grad so dreht steht einfach ist
dead also von wegen ist tot
ist hast du vermutlich ziemlich viele
Disney Filme gesehen habe ich nicht aber
das kennt man einfach mit diesen Strich
dadurch 6 der profitabelsten Fast Food
Restaurantketten was Platz 1 belegt
natürlich McDonald's
[Musik]
Platz 6 Subway Logos Link
es kann doch recht sein
boah nee ich sag links ich sag links
grüngelb ja das ist das
wir sagen wir sagen ein Extraleben LG
mit Punkt oder ohne mit Punkt weil es
soll eine Mischung sein aus einem L und
ein G aber auch so ein Gesichter Stellen
links 100 % mit natürlich hplg Fernseher
erkennst du das richtig
breit ja rechts so Punkt also musst ja
das ist es gut gemacht ich sag euch wie
jetzt mit Ansagen wenn ja solltest du
das hinkriegen falls nicht rate einfach
Nintendo Switch ist das rechte Logo weil
in dieser Animation geht er denn dieser
Controller runter und dann wird er auch
so weiß wenn er so eingeklackt ist so
vom Dingen eine geile Konsole no joke
ich weiß nicht über
[Musik]
welches ist das korrekte discord Logo
discord Logos links ne rechts ich will
jetzt auch nicht öffnen ich habe es auf
dem PC das ist mir egal einfach
richtig welches ist das korrekte Wappen
von Hogwarts wissen nur wahre Harry
Potter Fans ganz klar links das ist ja
auch das einzige wo die vier
Häuser drin sind
es ist dieses na erkannt ja klar also
hier ist ja zweimal sogar diese Schlange
von slipperin eine weitere Frage für
Gamer welches ist das korrekte
Playstation Logo rechts auch ein sehr
sehr sehr sehr wildes Logo aber
mittlerweile nutzen das kann das wäre so
cool wenn ich das doch benutzen würden
meiner Playstation finde ich da machen
sie leider nicht das ist das sehr gut
erst recht wenn du mit Videospielen
nichts am Hut hast doch
ziemlich gut Internet Browser weltweit
ist Google Chrome Opera hat es nicht mal
in die Top 3 geschafft kennst du denn
das richtige Logo wenn in Top 13 Google
Chrome
Firefox und Internet Explorer dann kommt
Opera das Logo ist das rechte glaube ich
nee das linke links links nach rechts
habe ich doch gesagt
und noch ein Aufruf an kaffeefans und
Donut Liebhaber weißt du welches das
richtige Logo ist rechts
100% ist es oben pink und unten
orange
100%. ich gehe zwar nicht
du kennst doch bestimmt das korrekte
Nutella Logo Nutella ist rechts
100%. boah Nutella krank bester Geruch
der Welt no joke selbstverständlich es
ist das hier ja erkennst du das
einzigartige Shell Logo rechts 100%ig
weil daher schnell dann äh steht links
sieht auch irgendwie ein bisschen
komisch aus links sieht sehr indisch
irgendwie aus das Logo finde ich genau
er war nicht schwer oder nein
nicht schwer dieser Kreis hat einen
Bissen abbekommen
Apple
aber hatten wir das nicht schon mal
ich glaube wir hatten das schon mal mit
diesem
dass das ist ein Apfel kein Kreis so
erkenne ich ihn auch ich glaube wir
hatten schon mal dass das so gezeichnet
war
ein paar kleine Punkte das kommt mir
seltsam bekannt vor haben das jetzt
einfach kopiert und da dran gepackt oder
oder wie jetzt genau das Google Logo ist
unverwechselbar egal wie vereinfacht ist
dargestellt wird warte wir machen noch
eins das hier sieht aus wie eine Wolke
stimmt ein Hinweis
oder hatten wir das doch noch nicht
ey ich habe schon noch so viele Videos
reagiert skype ist das glaube ich ne
oder das ist Twitter nee Skype okay wir
machen noch eins und schauen mal dieses
Lokal doch das hatten wir schon aber das
ist Adidas meine Damen und Herren würde
ich an der Stelle das heutige Video dann
auch beenden sorry dass das jetzt so ein
kleines zwischen Lückenfüller Video
heute war aber ich war mit meinen Jungs
im Giga Center und ähm mit einer Box
allerdings meine Damen und Herren hoffe
ich dass euch dieses Video heute dennoch
gefallen hat wenn es das getan hat das
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nichts
verpassen und schaut selbstverständlich
auf jeden Fall vorbei Look Schuh auf
Youtube jeden Tag kommen dort Videos
reactions auf interessante Themen
lustige Videos Rätsel lifehacks
ja